we are pleased to have our first guest
here on day number 4 be one of the top
quarterbacks in the entire National
Football League certainly in terms of
passing yards forty-nine hundred and two
passing yards second only to Jameis
Winston a career-high 30 touchdown
passes for the Dallas Cowboys the
quarterback of America's Team dak
Prescott good to see you sir I'm excited
I'm excited to be here they've at me
yeah you are you are most welcome how do
I I mean do I call you a free agent
quarterback sitting here what do I call
you Dan um is it my first time going
through this you tell me call me
whatever I guess I will call you Jack
Prescott it works the quarterback to the
National Football League who deserves to
get let me use the word Piz aid how does
that sound I like it yeah I can you know
I know your agents are over here I don't
mean to take their their gig away from
them but how do you feel this season
went for you jack
I mean obviously I'm somebody I want to
win I want wins circle is that so it
wasn't a success obviously didn't make
the playoffs that was that's the as the
man said you want to have an opportunity
to play in this game when you don't make
the playoffs that's not realistic so but
for me individually I took a step I
think I took a step in the going to the
next level of where I want to be and
improving in the passing game I still
want to be more consistent there's
obviously areas that I continue to grow
from and clean up right I feel like I
took a step to share individually well
and in terms of you having to go about
your business with your business
somewhat open-ended yeah I I'm not a
quarterback in the league okay I've
never had somebody actually while I'm
trying to broadcast try to hit me okay
so there's not many other parallels but
I am in a business where you go contract
a contract contract and if I'm in a walk
year and somebody isn't signing me to
the manner in which I want to be signed
it it's not easy and I'm wondering how
you went about your business this year
yeah it's not easy disappointing but
that's not something I worry about our
once the season started once once I knew
for a fact the contract wasn't getting
done I was focused on my team and I was
focused on that that shared commitment
that I had with those guys and I had
nothing to do with my individual getting
a contract or money I'm gonna make that
went out the window and that wasn't a
factor or anything that ever crossed
into my head
so just once week one hit you knew that
was it but you you weren't gonna talk
week 4 week 5 I think it went a little
bit and I want to sales about week for
week 5 that hey a it's not gonna get
done
we'll talk about it again after the
season and for me it was that's fine it
is what it is that's part of it I'm a
control what I can control yeah and
that's going out there and preparing to
be my best on Sunday and what what what
what does it mean to bet on yourself
what does that mean yeah I mean you
believe in yourself you have the
confidence in yourself you're not
listening to your doubters you're not
listening to the people that think you
can't do something and that's how I've
been my whole life if I've ever listened
or ever took an account with others
thought of me I wouldn't be here with
you today so I mean I've got all the
comedy to myself I'll bet on myself
again and again and where'd he get that
from what do you pick just the way I was
raised just facing adversity and
overcoming adversity and knowing that
with the right mindset with being
positive and being optimistic
controlling words you can control um
everything's in front of you and for me
that's how it's been throughout my life
and I've just I'll continue to continue
to move dak Prescott here courtesy by
the way of our friends of at Sleep
Number when we talk about it all the
time here and we'll talk a little bit
more about it with you in a second if
you could just be a fan okay a fan yeah
to put hard-earned dak Prescott dollars
down to pay to watch one quarterback
play in this league who would that be
one more time if you were just a fan
yeah and you would pay you could pay to
say see one quarterback perform live go
to a game because you wanted to see this
quarterback perform who would that be
it'd probably be Lamar Jackson for me
just watching him play um it's exciting
it's something I've never obviously
never really truly seen before
I'm just how I lose if he is how fast he
is his sudden change and then for him to
do all that and then stop and throw the
ball I think it'd be impressive to watch
just as a fan yeah I mean have you ever
seen him live I don't think you have
this cowboy we've never played him we're
never seen him play life that's just
it's just so what it just looks on
television a little bit different yeah
when you're knowing the speed of the
game obviously I mean the speed and
knowing the position yeah when I watch
him it just looks different when I watch
little more ejection I can't watch it as
a quarterback and I get to watch it as a
fan
sure I just think that's fun I think
he's he's a great player dak Prescott
here on the Rich Eisen show what do you
so now here at this Super Bowl Super
Bowl 54 how do you see this X's and O's
working this weekend Niners vs. chief
yeah I mean I didn't play either these
teams so I don't want to go in depth and
act like I know that much about them no
kind of this game of the 49ers and what
they're doing and know that defense and
obviously what Pat mahomes and in those
weapons with the play call in the van do
you read I mean I think it's gonna be a
great matchup I think a lot of points
are still gonna be scored even with the
San Fran's defense but I don't know it's
hard for me to pick two days ago I said
the Niners yesterday I said the Chiefs
and so I guess today I got to go back to
the knight who by the way that's not a
bad way to go and look I understand
you've got a ton of playing days left
but you do know what the previous
quarterback of the Dallas Cowboys is
getting paid to talk about football
right yeah I mean that's just I mean you
have the possibility of setting things
up for yourself that's great to look
forward to and Tony Tony does a great
job but call them my gosh I mean you
know you obviously with Tony and you
taking over the reins right there you
may have gotten him a pay raise if you
think about that as a conversation me
and Tony have dad when I get back to
dine Joyce calling the Super Bowl I mean
you're kind of on a nice career path
right now is your that's what I'm trying
to give you a little about a paparazzi
time right here if you want it they
paved the way I mean definitely
especially being being a part of the
Cowboys organization and obviously at
this position not many positions in all
of sports comparable to the Dallas
Cowboys quarterback and you see when you
play it's a great platform but even as
you go on Tony and Troy is showing you
that these show at dak Prescott here on
the Rich Eisen show have you spoken to
Mike McCarthy I have being Mike McCarthy
shared a phone conversation just
excitement on both ends just excited to
play for him and then he showed his
excitement to coach and he's won a Super
Bowl I'm excited just to get to work and
and chase that okay but you got to get
your business handles first right right
all right so you I'm seeing you said in
other interviews you're confident
something's gonna get done all the
confidence yeah I'm definitely confident
I mean I'm always coming to myself I bet
it all myself was confident in that I'm
confident my agents and my team getting
something done
I have confidence in the Cowboys okay so
I'm gonna ask you the question this way
about what contract you think you're
gonna get okay in terms of pi as I've
heard there's less PI I've heard there's
more that's right there's there's
there's Jerry Jones right there the
voice of Jerry Jones we've heard there's
less PI we've heard there's more pie I'm
wondering if you think this is deep-dish
pie how deep is it is it a deep-dish pie
if I'm guessing I'd say yeah okay
is it franchise pie I would say you'd
say well I mean I don't know what kind
of franchise tag I don't know I mean
long term pie is it long term pie I
don't know I just want a piece of the
pie just put it like that okay yeah okay
and is it is it a pie that that starts
with a four is it a pie that starts to
the fourth I could just said I'm leaving
up to my agents to cut my piece of the
pie I'm just ready for it and ready to
eat okay when that happens I'm ready to
get to work and excited for this
offseason and we've also heard through
DeMarcus Ware told us that when you sit
in Jerry's office have you gotten the
Jerry's office meeting yet I've been in
Jerry's office okay and that he lights a
candle turns the lights down and gives
you a whole Dallas Cowboy speech if you
had that you have not had that yeah he
says that that happens when he's trying
to close a deal so I think you'll know
that you're really close if you walk and
it's turned off like to throw down thank
you for that of that warning in that
heads-up just now I know like what's
going on when that habit is apparently a
votive candle with a Dallas Cowboy star
right on the side of it I don't know if
it's scented it's the make me to smell
it make me the smell of pie of some sort
I'm just saying that hasn't happened yet
it's what you're saying okay when you
get that call you know wow I'm closer
okay just trying to I'm just trying to
help you out right you got it
so let's talk about your relationship
with sleep number and what you're doing
in accordance with them yeah I mean
obviously I married Sleep Number I'm
excited to be a been partner with him
going on my second year and last year
throughout the middle of the years when
I first got my Sleep Number bed and
I was a little rebellious to get in it
and at the time I didn't want to get it
we were three and five but sure enough
listen my agent when got it went late in
it and became and became a believer of
the Sleep Number because of what it did
for me the advantage he gave me I was
able to track it like I do my my
weightlifting like I do my eating
regimen and it allowed me to improve I
mean last year two years ago I'm sorry
you look at the season where three and
five went on make the playoffs made a
big run Sleep Number takes credit for it
and I give it to them but it's
definitely my competitive edge and I'm
here sharing that with everyone my Sleep
Number setting is sixty
what's your set Mon it's been 40 lately
this offseason I've played with it for a
little bit but the past year and a half
it's been 40 it's 40 for me but yeah
just trying to turn see something out
you like a little on the on the softer
so I do I do it in the past I've been a
little more firm so that's why I'm
trying to turn it turn it back up okay
so there again I'm just trying to figure
out the Sleep Number in relation to the
PI number this is a math this is math we
could figure this whole thing out no I
know you got the the anti snore function
as well you got the whole thing working
here so and then the Sleep stick the 360
smart bed we've been talking about it
like it just to you to sleeping you
keeping you comfortably throughout the
entire night so yeah I mean you said
checking your heart rate being able to
tell how restless you are I was great
for me plus I have the pullet that
pulling heated mattress I like it cold
like my room dark okay that's the best
all right before I let you go what is
Daniel Jones getting with Jason Garrett
is his offensive coordinator yeah he's
getting a great coach he'll be excited
for him I think he'll do a lot of first
career I mean I know Jason deserves a
lot of a lot of credit for my
development and so so appreciative for
what he did did for me believing in me
and drafted me but not only that
coaching me and pushing me to the player
that I am now he's got a good coach well
I mean it was definitely a difficult
time obviously with with all you know
seriousness about what was going on with
you and Romo at the time and Jason had
to had to navigate all that that is not
an easy thing for a coach to do how did
he how did he help you in that process
as you were going here imagine that that
was easy but he believed in me
that's what that conversation was when
they came around is hey we believe in
you you got us here we're gonna we're
gonna ride this out in from that moment
that was a big moment for me right I
mean not only did he drive me but in
this this position in the midst of this
controversy they're sticking with me and
he did and he believed in me and that
goes a long way I'm he prepares like no
other and he's a great coach and happy
for him so he does more than just clap
right I mean he's a great coach he
prepares you know he's one of the best
when it comes to preparation it's a lot
of crap for the whole clapping thing you
know but it it it works it works yeah I
mean I'm a big clapper myself I'm gonna
have five guy but yeah I mean I guess I
guess you've got to watch it now and
this world how often that you do I guess
not exactly
and speaking of enthusiasm one last
thing for you here
Mike Leach doesn't leap out at me as a
guy who likes cowbells very much or
understands what he needs to do with the
cowbell you saw that video of him coming
off the flight being named at your alma
mater is the new way whether he knows
what to do it not he's trying I got off
the plane ringing the bell and we're
thankful to have him I think he's it's
an exciting hi I'm excited to watch that
program watch where they go from here I
know a lot of balls are gonna be thrown
yeah and excited for what he's gonna do
a beast a it's just what do you think he
needs to do here or does even work just
a little bit tighter with the wrist he's
got in a great posture got the cowbell
huh just just move it around coach you
know just get it working right there I
like it hey Jack thanks for coming on
when the pie comes out of the oven you
know give me a call and we'll talk about
the pie how just how deep it is how much
there how much less there's remaining
and and how how it how expensive the pie
is and and again if you ever saw the
movie Hoosiers where coach Dale asks the
guy to play defense so tight that he
wanted to get a report on the flavor of
gum that the defender was chewing I want
I want a report on what the
of the candalas and Jerry Jones is
office okay that's it I want all that
that's that Prescott here on the Rich
Eisen show for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 under
red TV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app